الان الى الملف النوويه الايراني حيث قال
المرشد الايراني علي خمينائي ان بلاده لا
تعارض ابرام اتفاقيات بشان ملفها النووي
شارطه الحفاظ على البنيه التحتيه لصناعتها
النوويه واعتبر المرشد الايراني ان من
وصفهم بالاعداء يتخذون سلاح النووي ذريعه
لمنع بلاده من التقدم في المجالات العلميه
واوضح خامنئي عقب زيارته معرض انجازات
الصناعات النوويه الايرانيه في طهران ان
ايران لا تسعى الى تطوير سلاح النووي
واضاف ان بلاده ترفض امتلاك اسلحه الدمار
الشامل
موجوده يجب الحفاظ على البنى التحتيه في
صناعتنا النوويه خلال هذه السنوات تمكنا
من تحقيق انجازات مهمه من الممكن ان تبرم
اتفاقيات في بعض الامور ولا مشكله في ذلك
لا نعارض ابرام اتفاقيات في الملف النووي
شريطه الحفاظ على البنيه التحتيه في صناعه
النوويه يجب ان نحافظ على هذه الانجازات
التي تحققت خلال سنوات بفضل جهود خبرائنا
صلاه واضاف البرشد الايراني ان بلاده لا
تسعى الى تطوير سلاح نووي لانه يخالف
مبادئها وقال خلال لقائه المسؤولين
والعاملين في الصناعات النوويه الايرانيه
ان العدو يتخذ السلاح النووي ذريعه ضد
طهران لمنع يامن في المجالات العلميه حسب
تعبيره
نواجه تحديا منذ عشرين عاما العدو خلق هذه
التحديات النوويه ويدعي انه قلق من السلاح
النووي رغم ان الاعداء يعلمون وواثقون
باننا لا نسعى الى امتلاك سلاح النووي لا
نسعى الى تطوير سلاح النووي وهذا ليس خوفا
من الاعداء بل انه يخالف مبادئنا وديننا
ونرفض امتلاك اي اسلحه دمار شامل العدو
يتخذ سلاح النووي ذريعه لمنعنا من التقدم
في المجالات العلميه